hey you guys I'm Katie Kraus I'm Oscar
Gracie and I'm Kristen Gill and we are
here to talk about all things Taylor
Swift but I want to put out there
we built this wall before we knew we
were ever gonna do this on camera we
understand the level of crazy but that
is how we are we are massive insane
Swifty's I've met Taylor you've met -
yeah I'm a tailor in 2007 so this goes
back guys way back I mean that's over a
decade ago you spent time with her dad
I've spoken with her mom I have a
craziest an account so fun we're also
gonna talk about some of your guys's fan
theories that we've dug up but I want to
start with this just take a look with
1989 I love this album so much that I
think it would be doing a real
disservice to this album to try and copy
it the next time around but I think it's
gonna have to be something very very
different creatively do you feel like
that goes with this Mary man this was
the album after 1989 or not I don't know
I feel like what what she said it kind
of tees up that she wanted to make
something like reputation something
completely different so maybe that's
what yeah so I think that might be
bunking yes but I also feel like she
might have been sitting on something
because to create this crazy world that
were diving into right now yes there had
to have been something that she bounced
off of him was like I've got to be able
to tie it into this yeah and this I
don't understand how you could not
fangirl about that we're gonna talk
about our new theories first of all
number one the hearts guys if you look
she is captioned hearts on various new
Instagram pictures does it mean I heart
that's the 14th see yeah there's
something going on because even when she
announced her record label swap she had
the heart stamp on her eye and I saw
that and I was like what is my little
sis up to and then coming back with all
these freaking heart captions
something's going on so now I mean I was
made a fool just a week ago so we were
all gonna call them but yeah I'm ready
to put it on the line again and say like
maybe this means the song will be
something like heart beat or something
like that I don't know that's just what
I'm saying okay
yeah and I think it's I heart I'm
getting I didn't know be like I heart
and they could all be tight and like her
concerts when she does the heart what a
throwback
like maybe it is I heart and it's a
concert related something or Hoonah I
don't know that an awards show like
reveals yes like with bad blood that was
Ramirez yeah word show it delicate
premiered on an award show she uses
those award shows man she looks to take
him over she's smart
okay next theory book chapters pages I
mean she's referenced so many times like
I can't wait for you guys to see my next
chapter I'm even more excited about the
next chapter she loves a good book
do we think maybe I kind of think it
could be pages like she's a writer she's
written two essays seven days apart or
they've come out seven days apart all
about like how much she appreciates
writing yeah could it be book themed
like you know what I mean I could the
album be let's not forget a story of us
what an iconic pop that was and even
when she was younger she like says that
she used to write books all the time
yeah like you said she's reference books
so much and she's always seeing her life
in these chapters in a different book so
I could totally see her coming through
I'm saying eternal but that's only
because of a fan theory that I heard and
now I'm like my mind is blown okay so
this is why I am so inspired by the palm
and eternal theory speak now Stan
thirteen is also all about the palm
theory and this is what they say they
noticed that there was embroidery on her
dress in May in May of 2018 on this pink
dress at the Billboard Awards that says
eternal and Palms mean eternal life and
then Larissa Sophie is also about the
palm trees but she says the policeman in
the photo she posted on Instagram means
that she's coming out with the album on
four twelve twenty nineteen what you
guys is really just over a month away
and Jaya via things that the album is
going to come out on Easter because the
old tailor is not bad and lastly I have
to call out TS updates and why who we've
been following on Twitter forever who
noticed that on Taylor's YouTube it says
that there are 245 videos but actually
there's only 243 so are there to
unlisted hidden videos already uploaded
to her page okay I'm done that's it you
can't possibly be that surprised all at
the time but here's what we do know so
Taylor is kind of hinted in these two
new Elle covers about what the new sound
is gonna be and I think one of my
favorite things that she said is that
you don't have to be sad or heartbroken
to find inspiration like she said you
can find inspiration and be happy at the
same time so I think that's our biggest
clue right so she's been asked like from
the beginning of her career what are you
gonna do when you finally like all in
love and get married and have kids like
are we gonna write song so this is the
album we're finally gonna get that I
have that put to the test
I caught it let me get into how crazy
like you got me with all of this because
I'm a super fan and like I cry when she
comes out on stage I'm the fan that's
crying you know I'm sure you guys are
too but like I'm crying right laughs oh
yeah last night my husband tonight he's
a singer-songwriter guy and we went
through as cap and BMI and downloaded
Max Martin and Jack Antonoff
song history of what the songs that
they've licensed the FBI is here we were
that crazy just so you know nothing is
out yet confirmed nothing is on their
page God we have someone on that so
before we wrap up very quickly vinyl
album prediction for this week eternal
okay I'm going pages or something book
really good I'm just thinking with
heartbeat they love that hard to throw
but bringing it back let us know what
you guys think though in the comments on
all things social media we want to keep
doing this we've worked really just too
hard not to we're getting to this so
we'll see you next time
[Music]